Bitte schön.
Schönen guten Abend. Mein Name ist Dane Kojasaraj. Ich bin heute die Dienstabende Erddin hier und würde jetzt gerne mit Ihnen ein Anamnese-Gespräch führen. Sind Sie da mit einverstanden?
Was heißt Anamnese-Gespräch?
Anamnese-Gespräch ist genauso das, was wir jetzt machen. Anamnese ist eine Befragung, damit wir ihre aktuelle Bechwerden sprechen und eine Diplose vorstellen.
Ja, das können wir so machen.
Okay. Bevor wir über ihre aktuelle Bechwerden sprechen, möchte ich ganz schnell ihre Personnhedaten aufnehmen. Wie ist Ihr Name?
Ich heiße Gisela Hanke.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Nachname buchstabieren?
Ja, Hanke schreibt sich Ha, A, N, K, E. Hanke.
Hanke, Frau Hanke, wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt und geboren bin ich am 21. Mai 1968.
Okay. Frau Hanke, wie groß sind Sie?
1,61 m.
Können Sie Ihre Aktuellen gewicht?
Ja, so 82 kg. Das ist zu viel.
Okay. Frau Hanke, was für Bechwerden haben Sie?
Ja, seit 2 Stunden. Das war ziemlich genau vor 2 Stunden, ist das angefangen.
Da wurde mir plötzlich unwohl. Mir wurde übel. Ich hatte Übelkeit und habe auch einmal erbrochen.
Ich hatte dabei ein starkes Druckgefühl im Oberbauch, unter den Brustbein und hinter den Brustbein.
Das tut mir ziemlich weh. Das ist so ein Druck.
Ich habe auch etwas Luftnot.
Okay. Wie können Sie diese Schmerzen, also wo genau sind diese Schmerzen? Oberbauch und auch Brustbein.
Ganz oben im Bauch, also unterhalb des Brustbeines und hinter dem Brustbein.
Okay. Wie können Sie diese Schmerzen genauer beschreiben,
denn Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben Druckgefühl, aber...
Es ist mehr so drückend. Drückend und dumpf mehr.
Dabei ist mir eben übel und ich habe auch erbrochen. Mir geht es nicht gut.
Einmal haben Sie erbrochen?
Ja, bisher einmal erbrochen. Aber übel ist mir weiterhin.
Okay. Wie können Sie diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala einordnen, wobei nun keine und sie unerträglich sind?
Ich würde sagen bei sechs.
Okay. Streiten diese Schmerzen in anderen Körperteilen aus?
Nein.
Okay.
Okay. Haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden, ähnliche Schmerzen?
Ich erinnere mich so ungefähr vor zwei Wochen.
Da wollte ich gerade in unsere Wohnung, wir wohnen im zweiten Stockwerk
und da wollte ich die Treppe steigen, hatte eine schwere Einkaufstasche
und da hatte ich so ähnliche Beschwerden, aber nicht so stark.
Wie waren links nicht so stark wie jetzt?
Nur einmal haben Sie diese Beschwerden.
Ja.
Und das war bei Belastung?
Also beim Treppensteigen.
Haben Sie damals etwas getan oder?
Nein, ich habe abgewartet.
Ich musste dann noch eine halbe Treppe gehen.
Ich habe erst mal eine Minute, zwei Minuten da gestanden im Treppenhaus
und dann bin ich in die Wohnung gegangen.
Aber habe mein Mann nichts davon erzählt und auch meiner Familie nicht
und war auch nicht beim Arzt deswegen.
Okay.
Frau Hanke, jetzt möchte ich diese Analysegespräch unterbrechen
und ganz schnell bei Ihnen eine EKG schreiben
und auch Vitalparameter bei Ihnen messen.
Was sind Vitalparameter?
Vitalparameter bestehen auf Puls, Blutdruck, Körpertemperatur
und Sauerstoffkategorien, damit wir Sie eine Maschine anschließen.
Wenn Sie sich wohlfühlen, können wir weiter.
Okay.
Frau Hanke, Sie haben schon erwähnt, seit zwei Stunden haben Sie diese
Beschwerden, haben Sie diese Schmerzen und gleichzeitig ein bisschen
Luftnot und Überkeit.
Haben Sie weitere Beschwerden?
Haben Sie Fieber, Schütterfroh-
Luftnot, Überkeit und ich habe einmal erbrochen.
Wobei die Luftnot, ja, die ist da aber nicht so stark.
Aber am meisten ist dieses Druckgefühl und dieser Schmerz hinterm
Brustbein und dem Oberbauch, das ist das Schlimmste.
Okay.
Schwitzen Sie Fernmerz oder haben Sie Katzschweiß?
Nein.
Okay.
Fernmerzen Sie einen Auslöser?
Also das war jetzt heute Morgen beim Frühstück.
Ich wollte gerade anfangen mit dem Frühstück und da plötzlich
kamen diese Beschwerden.
Nach dem Frühstück?
Nein, vor dem Frühstück.
Vor dem Frühstück.
Ich wollte gerade beginnen.
Gibt es bestimmte, haben Sie etwas bemerkt, eine Linderung
oder eine Verstärkung, etwas Bestimmtes in Zusammenhang?
Ich habe mich ruhig verhalten.
Also ich wollte mich gar nicht groß bewegen.
Ich habe mich in den Sessel gesetzt und habe das Fenster
geöffnet, aber dann hat mein Mann gesagt, wir müssen jetzt
dann ins Krankenhaus.
Okay.
Sie haben, das ist die richtige Entscheidung.
Sie haben eine Entscheidung getroffen und Sie sind in
gutem Handel.
Frau Hanke, wir werden Ihnen alles mögliche machen, um Ihnen zu
helfen.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder Herzklopfen bemerkt?
Herzrasen nicht, aber vielleicht hat mein Herz etwas stärker
geklopft, etwas stärker geschlagen.
Das kann sein.
Aber Herzrasen habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Frau Hanke, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit geschwollene Beine bemerkt?
Also die Beine sind abends immer etwas geschwollene,
besonders wenn es jetzt, als es mal warm war in den Tagen
oder wenn ich länger gesessen habe beim Autofahren,
dann war das schon mal so.
Aber das hat mich nicht bestört.
Die waren am Morgen, nächsten Morgen wieder dünner, in der Schlange.
Okay. Können Sie vielleicht liegen, um eine Luft noch zu
bekommen?
Hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert, aber ich benutze eigentlich immer
ein Kissen.
Ein Kissen.
Zum Schlafen.
Okay.
Wie sieht Ihre Schlafqualität aus, Frau Hanke?
Ich schlafe eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich muss zwar zweimal in der Nacht auf Toilette und Wasser
lassen, aber ich kann danach wieder gut einschlafen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, da habe ich auch nicht noch nie Probleme gehabt.
Okay.
Haben Sie keine Durchfall bis morgen, oder?
Nein.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihre Petite, Frau Hanke?
Der ist gut, eigentlich zu gut.
Ich wiege ja zu viel eigentlich.
Ich wiege ja 82 kg, aber ein Meter 61 Größe.
Und ein Arzt auch immer, meine Ärzte, wäre so gut,
wenn ich mindestens mal 5 kg abnehmen würde.
Aber das fällt mir sehr schwer.
Das wäre auch gut für Ihre Gesundheit, Frau Hanke.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ungewollt zugenommen?
Nein.
Ich habe mein Gewicht eigentlich gehalten.
Ich muss immer aufpassen, dass es nicht weiter steigt.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie dort werden oder saures Aufstossen,
Frau Hanke?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Also, auch?
Auch nicht.
Okay.
Frau Hanke, leiden Sie an irgendwelche Chronischerkrankungen,
zum Beispiel Bluthofturö,
zu einer Krankheit?
Ja, habe ich.
Ich habe hohe Blutfettwerte, immer schon.
Ich glaube, das hat mein Vater auch gehabt.
Ich habe hohe Cholesterin, da muss ich auch eine Tablette nehmen.
Und das sogenannte, ich glaube, das heißt Neutralfett.
Das ist auch sehr hoch.
Aber ich nehme gegen das hohe Cholesterin nämlich eine Tablette
und dann habe ich seitdem eine Tablette.
Ich nehme eine Cholesterin nämlich eine Tablette.
Und dann habe ich seit acht Jahren Zucker.
Da nehme ich auch Tabletten.
Und ich habe seit ungefähr zwölf Jahren hohen Blutdruck.
Und dann nehme ich auch Tabletten.
Wie sind Sie die Tableten, Frau Hanke?
Ja, also beim Blutdruck heißt dieses Mittel,
Cannesatane, heißt das.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Da hinter steht acht.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens und eine Tablette abends.
Okay.
Und dann nehme ich noch gegen die Zucker, das heißt Metformin.
Okay, wie viel Milligramm?
Da steht hinter, 850.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens und eine Tablette abends.
Okay.
Ich nehme noch Rosu, das ist schwierig, das Wort Rosu,
was datin?
Da hinter steht 20.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens.
Okay.
Haben Sie weitere Medikamente?
Degenmäßig oder bei Bedarf?
weitere Medikamente nicht.
Ich hatte vor drei Jahren,
hatte der Augenarzt festgestellt,
dass meine Netzhaut wahrscheinlich durch den Zucker
Schädigungen hat und da wurde ich zweimal im Augenblick
inzwischen mit Laser behandelt.
Laser.
Okay.
Haben Sie jetzt beschwerden mit See?
Nein, im Augenblick nach der letzten Laserbehandlung,
ist das ganz gut geworden.
Das freut mich.
Hab gesehen diese Laserbehandlung,
sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, als Kind, ich weiß nicht genau, wie alt ich da war, 10 oder 11 Jahre alt,
weil ich am Blindarm operiert.
Und vor sechs Jahren wurde meine Gallenblase entfernt,
weil ich Gallensteine hatte und ich hatte auch einmal
Collagen, Gallen-Collagen, das war sehr schmerzhaft.
Und daraufhin hat man die Gallenblase entfernt.
Okay.
Vor sechs Jahren.
Ist bei Ihnen irgendeine Allergie oder
Unterzecklichkeit bekannt?
Nein.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft Frau Hanke?
Also meine Hausärztin, die sagte,
ja, ich brauche wegen meiner Erkrankungen wie Zucker,
muss ich auch immer Grippeimpfungen machen
und habe auch 4 Covid-Impfungen gemacht.
Und die anderen Impfungen glaube ich Wunsch-Tag-Kampf,
Diff-Touré und so, das ist alles in Ordnung zurzeit,
aber auch ich im Augenblick nichts.
Okay, das ist auch wichtig.
Grippeimpfung ist auch wichtig für Zucker-Patienten.
Dann habe ich noch eine Impfung bekommen,
die man sonst glaube ich etwas später impft.
Dann sagte mir der Arzt, aber weil ich Zucker habe
und hohe Brut auf gegen Lungen entzündet,
dann habe ich noch eine Impfung bekommen.
Okay.
Frau Hanke, wir sind fast durch noch ein paar Fragen.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, das ist ein Problem.
Ich rauche schon ziemlich lange.
Ich habe seit ca. 35 Jahren so ungefähr eine halbe Schachtel am Tag.
Halbe Schachtel.
Das ist auch viel, Frau Hanke.
Würde ich Ihnen empfehlen, ein bisschen,
am besten könnten Sie aufhören mit Rauchen,
aber wenn es nicht nur möglich ist,
könnten Sie ein bisschen weniger rauchen.
Ja, das ist auch mein Ziel.
Das habe ich mir fest vorgenommen.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie Alkohol zu sich, Frau Hanke?
Vielleicht zwei Gläserwein innerhalb einer Woche.
Routinemäßig muss ich fragen,
Frau Hanke, bitte nehmen Sie sich nicht persönlich.
Nehmen Sie Drogen oder haben Sie...
Nein.
Okay.
Frau Hanke, sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Die Mutter, die Mutter lebt noch.
Die Mutter ist 80 Jahre alt.
Die hat auch Alterszucker und sie hat Gelenkräume.
Und der Vater, der ist mit 65 Jahren
an einem Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß noch,
im Alter von 60 Jahren hatte er seinen ersten Herzinfarkt.
Das hatte er aber ganz gut überstanden,
aber dann mit 65 wieder einen Herzinfarkt
und daran ist er verstorben.
Das tut mir leid, Frau Hanke.
Haben Sie die Schwester?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder, der ist ein Jahr älter.
Er hat auch hohen Blutdruck
und er hatte vor einem Jahr einen Herzkatheter bekommen
und da wurden ihm in die Herzkanzgefäße
so zwei kleine Röhrchen eingelegt,
damit der Herzmuskel wieder besser durchblutet wird.
Und das ist gut geworden.
Also danach hat er praktisch keine Beschwerden mehr.
Das freut mich, Frau Hanke.
Sie haben schon erwähnt,
dass ich glaube, Sie sind verheiratet.
Ja.
Sie sind ein Kind?
Wir haben eine Tochter, die ist 25 Jahre alt.
Sie hat auch Probleme mit dem Körpergewicht.
Sie hat auch Übergewicht
und da macht sie jetzt im Augenblick
aber einen Purse über die Krankenkasse
und will sich mehr bewegen und weniger essen.
Ja, sie arbeitet da dran.
Ja.
Okay.
Ich bin angestellt in einer Bank.
Haben Sie sich Stress bei der Arbeit?
Nein, meine Arbeit ist ruhig.
Ich arbeite in einem Büro ohne Kundenkontakt.
Das ist manchmal Stress.
Ich glaube, ich am Schalter zu stehen.
Aber ich arbeite in einem Büro.
Ich mache Sachbearbeitung.
Okay, das freut mich.
Trägt ihr regelmäßig Sport?
Ich bemühe mich regelmäßig mit meinem Mann
zweimal, dreimal in der Woche spazieren zu gehen.
Wir fahren auch manchmal etwas Fahrrad.
Aber es fällt mir alles doch sehr schwer,
weil ich doch selber auch ein bisschen zu schwer bin.
Das spüre ich dann sehr schnell in den Knien
und in der Hüfte, wenn ich zu viel mache.
Ja, für Ihre Gesundheit würde ich sehr gerne Ihnen weiter empfehlen,
dass Sie vielleicht ein bisschen abnehmen könnten.
Das ist auch sehr, sehr wichtig.
Frau Hanke.
Meine Seite habe ich alle wichtige Informationen gesammelt.
Falls Ihnen noch etwas ein, oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich frage mich, was kann das sein?
Das macht mir schon sehr viel Sorgen.
Diese Schmerzen, diese Übelkeit.
Ich möchte, dass es mir bald wieder besser geht.
Ja, ich verstehe Ihre Sorgen.
Frau Hanke, jetzt ist es zu früh,
eine Diagnose festzulegen.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass Sie vielleicht
eine Herzkrankheit haben.
Aber muss ich
um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu verherzen,
muss ich ein paar Unterlagen
bei Ihnen durchführen.
Erstmal körperliche Untersuchung
und Laborwertebestimmung
und andere
bildgebende Verfahren.
Aber machen Sie die Anzahl?
Die Werte, die Sie gerade eben untersucht haben
beim EKG, Sie haben gesagt, ich messe den Sauerstoff.
Waren diese Werte denn in Ordnung?
Ja, ich werde alle in Ordnung
und alle Informationen, die Sie schon geschildert haben
und alle Ergebnisse
mit meinem Oberarzt sprechen.
Danach könnte ich Sie sagen,
dass Sie jetzt haben.
Jetzt hat er mein Blutdruck in Ordnung
und dieser Sauerstoff wird.
Sie haben das jetzt gerade gemessen.
Okay.
Haben Sie mich verstanden?
Ja.
Sie haben die Fallaufnahme unterbrochen
und haben gesagt, ich messe jetzt
Ihren Blutdruck, ich mache ein EKG, ich messe
Ihren Sauerstoff gehalten.
Sie haben sich jetzt virtuell gemacht
und jetzt fragt Frau Hanke aber diese Werte,
die Sie jetzt gerade gemessen haben, mein Blutdruck
ist in Ordnung oder verändert?
Muss ich mir da Sorgen machen?
Was kann ich antworten?
Ich könnte vielleicht sagen, Frau Hanke,
Ihr Blutdruck, der ist etwas erhöht.
Der ist bei 160 zu 100.
Der Sauerstoffwert im Blut ist aber
in Ordnung.
Und das EKG, das ich jetzt in Ordnung habe,
das ist ein kleines EKG,
das ist auch erstmal noch nicht auffällig.
Ich sehe keine Herzrhythmusstörungen
und sonst ist das EKG erstmal in Ordnung,
aber das kann sich eventuell noch im Laufe der nächsten
Stunden verändern.
Das wäre für Frau Hanke eine Beruhigung.
Also der Blutdruck ist etwas hoch,
Aufregung vielleicht, Stress,
SPO 2 ist in Ordnung,
von mir aus oder grenzwertig
und das EKG ist gut.
Das beruhigt Frau Hanke jetzt erstmal,
weil Frau Hanke fragt nach.
Sie haben ja die Anamnese unterbrochen,
habe gesagt, Frau Hanke, ich nehme jetzt einige Notwerte,
was ja auch sehr gut war.
Aber dann müssen Sie damit rechnen, dass Frau Hanke fragt,
dass sie das EKG aufwählen kann.
Ja, okay.
Zum Beispiel ein STH,
das EKG natürlich auffällig ist.
Dann hätten Sie wahrscheinlich die Anamnese
ganz unterbrochen,
hätten anders gehandelt,
sondern hätten gesagt, Frau Hanke, ich sehe
direkte Veränderungen im EKG, wir müssen
die Anamnese ergreifen, damit sie
gut stabilisiert sind und damit es ihnen bald
besser geht.
Weil dann sollten Sie nicht noch fragen,
Frau Hanke, haben Sie eine Tochter und was haben Sie
für Hobbys und machen Sie Sport?
Weil das ist dann sekundär.
Wichtiger wäre dann eine direkte Intervention.
Ja, okay.
Ich habe es gemacht.
Alles gut, nur Sie müssen damit rechnen, dass Frau Hanke
besorgt ist und Fragen stellt und sagt, was ist das
jetzt gewesen, was haben Sie gemessen?
Ist das gut?
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Frau Hanke,
hatten Sie in der letzten
Zeit eine zahnerzliche Behandlung gehabt?
Zahnerzliche Behandlung.
Im letzten halben Jahr nicht.
Die zweite Frage ist, wissen Sie, ob Ihre
Begleiterkrankungen gut eingestellt sind?
Ich gehe wegen dem Zucker,
jede Vierteljahr zu meinem Hausarzt,
da wird Blut gemessen,
der Langzeit, der Erkrankungen,
der Macht mit einer Stimmgabel,
der Untersuch der am Fuß, am Knöchel usw.
Ich gehe einmal im Jahr zu Augenärztin
und einmal im Jahr zum Diabetologen.
Das war in letzter Zeit eigentlich ganz gut.
Da waren die Leute zufrieden.
Sie sagen immer nur, ich muss, sollte Gewicht abnehmen.
Danke für die Antwort.
Vielen Dank.
Danke.
Keine Fragen, Kollegen.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen.
Wie sind die Schmerzen
eingefangen, aufgetreten,
plötzlich oder langsam?
Anfang mit den Frühstücken
und dann begann das, das begann relativ plötzlich.
Okay.
Die Schmerzen mit der Zeit herrnert.
Hat sich die Schmerzen mit der Zeit herrnert?
Die Schmerzen sind ziemlich gleich geblieben.
Bechternd.
Keine Welinfirmung? Nein, nicht erln.
Standig, bechternd.
Und genekologische Situation
haben wir, müssen wir fragen,
ich gehe regelmäßig
zu meiner Genekologin,
zu Vorsorguntersuchungen.
Und die Periode ist so im letzten
Jahr unregelmäßiger geworden.
Besten Jahr unregelmäßiger.
Danke schön.
Können wir Arsatz gesprungen fangen?
Fabian.
Gut.
Schönen guten Abend, Herr Oberalz.
Ich möchte Ihnen über
meine neue Patientin berichten.
Sie ist Frau Githela Hanke.
Sie ist 56 Jahre alt.
1,61 groß und 82 kg schwer.
Frau Hanke
stellte sich bei der
heute bei uns wegen
seit zwei Stunden
plötlich aufgetretenen
Retro-Schmerzen
und Oberarbeaufschmerzen
ohne Ausstrahlung vor.
Schmerzintensität sei 6 von
10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Die Schmerz-Sympathie
ist auf einer Schmerzskala.
Sie bezeichnet die Schmerzen
durkend und durst.
Es ist erwähnt,
dass sie ähnliche Schmerzen
vor zwei Wochen bei Belastung
erlebt haben.
Aber
haben sie
keine Arzt besucht?
Sie haben keine Arzt besucht?
Sie haben eine Schwierigkeits-
und Verstärkendefaktoren
von den Schmerzen.
Sie haben eine Art
von Schmerz-Sympathie
mit der Schmerz-Sympathie.
Sie haben eine Art
von Schmerz-Sympathie
mit der Schmerz-Sympathie
mit der S lysie.
S tiesie?
Wie 식t ihr das Erbrochene Auß amor?
Vielleichtchanging
wiederholen, was sie mir geschildert haben. Frau Hankel ist eine 56-jährige Patientin in
übergewichtigen EZ, 1,61 groß, 82 Kilogramm schwer. Sie klagt seit zwei Stunden über
unwohl sein. Nausia emesis einmalig. Das Erbrochene haben wir noch nicht geplärt, wie es aussieht.
Darüber hinaus klagt sie über Schmerzen im Abdomen. Sie haben gesagt im Bauch sagen sie lieber Schmerzen
im Epigastrium, weil der Schmerz war direkt unterhalb des Brustbeins, also Schmerzen im Epigastrium
und retro-sternal. Dann haben wir die Lokalisierung gut beschrieben. Oder sie klagt über epigastrische
Schmerzen und retro-sternale Schmerzen, ohne Ausstrahlung. Ähnliche Schmerzen hatte die
Patientin ähnliche Schmerzen, aber nicht so stark. Hatte die Patientin vor zwei Wochen im Sinne
einer Belastungsgeschwere Symptomatik, also bei Belastung, bei körperlicher Belastung. Gut.
Und es besteht eine Dispräve. Und fahren Sie bitte fort. Ist bei Frau Hanke aufgefallen, dass sie
Abels, Bein-Ödeme habe. Und an der vegetative Anamnese bis auf Insomnia wegen eines Zweimal
Lichter ist unauffällig. An der geneikologischen Anamnese habe sie eine genmäßige menstruation
seit einem Jahr. Aber sie ist unter Kontrolle beim Frauenarzt. Und er vor Erklang zum Gen
leiden sie hypercholesterinämie und seit zwölf Jahren arterialer Hepatone und seit acht
Jahren Zuka Diabetes Meditus. Aus Nebenbei haben sie Retinopathy erlebt, für drei Jahre
wegen Diabetes Meditus, aber mit Laser behandelt wurde.
Kurz, kurze Unterbrechung. Berichten Sie dem Oberarzt ruhig. Also sie kommt mit Schmerzen,
Retrostenal, Grad 6 mit Dispneu, mit Emesis Nausea und sagen daraufhin, Stopp, daraufhin habe ich die
Anamnese unterbrochen und die Vitalparameter kontrolliert, einschließlich EKG. Weil das ist
wichtig, dass sie das mitteilen. Weil bei so einem Fall haben sie ja richtig gehandelt,
aber das sollten sie auch gleich berichten. In der Chronologie, dann ist der Oberarzt beruhigt,
sagt ja sehr gut. Die Kollegin hat richtig gehandelt, sie hat die Vitalparameter kontrolliert.
Dann können sie sagen, die Kontrolle der Vitalparameter war bis auf einen leicht
höhten Blutdruck von 160 zu 100, zunächst unauffällig. Das war es ja auch. Und dann
sind sie erst mal können sie weitermachen. Weil sonst fragt der Oberarzt ja und wie
sind die Vitalparameter, haben sie die denn kontrolliert? Das ist immer besser, wenn sie es
gleich sagen. Ja, gut. Aber in der Prüfung müssen wir eine Fantasie haben, nicht glaube ich.
Nein, nein, diese Station ist sehr gut in der Prüfung. Ich würde da ruhig in der Prüfung das so machen,
weil ich habe von einigen schon gehört, dass das auch positiv aufgenommen wird.
Ja. Ich würde ruhig sagen in so einem Fall wie retro- sternaler Schmerz, ein Fall mit akuter
Dispnö oder einen Fall mit starken akuten Kopfschmerzen oder so. Sollten sie sagen, ich unterbreche
jetzt und möchte erst mal mir ein Bild von ihnen machen und messe einige Werte, Blutdruck,
EKG, Sauerstoff in Blut, um sie optimal betreuen zu können. Und das beruhre ich die Patientin.
Das ist für sie wichtig und es macht einen guten Eindruck auf die Prüfung. Okay. Dankeschön.
Und gegen diese chronische Erkrankungen nehmen sie regelmäßig, kann es halt am 8mg zweimal
täglich mit Formin 850mg, zweimal täglich und Rosovastatin 20mg einmal täglich. Gut. Ist die
Patientin schon einmal operiert worden? Ja. Die Patientin wurde in ihrer Kinderhalt appendectomiert
und vor sechs Jahren scholezustectomiert. Ein schwieriges Wort. Machen Sie es etwas einfacher.
Vor sechs Jahren erfolgte eine scholezustectomie. Ist vielleicht etwas einfacher. Ja. Weshalb
erfolgte die scholezustectomie? Wissen Sie das? Okay. Gut. Ist bei der Patientin keine Allergien
oder Unverzweglichkeiten bekann. Frau Hanke ist Raucherin. Seit 35 Jahren Raucher sie halbe
Schachtel und trinke alkohol regelmäßig. Zwei Gläserwein, wöchentlich. Drogenkonsum wurde
verneinbar. Zwei Gläserwein pro Woche. Und dafür Familien anamnese sind folgende zu sagen. Ihr Vater ist mit
65 Jahren gestorben. Herzinfarkt. Herzinfarkt. Genau. Myokartinfarkt.
Herzinfarkt. Sie ist 80 Jahre alt und leidet Diabetes Meditus und Promotoid Artritis.
Gut. Okay. Gibt es Geschwister? Ja. Sie habe einen Bruder, der an arterialer
Hiparthonie leidet und ist bei dem Bruder auch Myokartinfarkt bekannt mit Angioplastie behandelt.
Also bei dem Bruder ist wahrscheinlich noch kein Myokartinfarkt. Ich habe gesagt, der Bruder
hatte vor einem Jahr eine Herzkatheter-Untersuchung und da wurden ihm bei der Untersuchung Röhrchen,
also so kleine Röhrchen in die Herzkanzgefäße eingelegt. Wahrscheinlich besteht bei dem Bruder
eine Meergefäß-KHK und er hat Stents bekommen. Das heißt aber noch nicht, dass er schon einen
Myokartinfarkt hatte. Wahrscheinlich hatte er Anginapectoris Beschwerden und da wurde ein
Katheter gemacht und man hat festgestellt, es besteht eine interventionsbedürftige KHK
und man hat ihn gestentet. Also noch kein Myokartinfarkt. Der 58-jährige Bruder leidet an
arteriellen Hypertones und vor einem Jahr erfolgte wohl eine BTCA, wahrscheinlich vor dem Hintergrund
einer coronaren Herzerkrankung. Mehr weiß die Patientin aber nicht. Ja, was ist denn Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Aufgrund der anhaltlichen Angaben habe ich Verdacht auf akute Coronasindrom und als Alternative kommen
Pulmonarembolier oder Artdefektion auch in Betracht. Gut, also ich denke die Verdachtstiagnose eines
guten Coronasyndroms ist aufgrund von einigen Symptomen und der anamnistischen Angabe der
Risikofaktoren der Familienvorgeschichte ist das zunächst denke ich die wichtigste Diagnose, die
auch eventuell am meisten Konsequenzen hat, wenn sie übersehen wird. Das kann natürlich auch vielleicht
eine akute Markengeschichte sein, akute Probleme aus Gastritis, mit Übelkeit und epigastischen
Schmerz, aber es ist eher unwahrscheinlich. Ja, ich würde auch diese Verdachtstiagnose auch nennen,
das ist ganz klar. Ja, ich finde das haben Sie gut gemacht zum wiederholten Mal. Letzten Mal haben
Sie das ja auch schon gut gemacht. Wann haben Sie Prüfung morgen? Am 19. August. Okay, da haben
Sie das bald geschafft. Ein kleiner Tipp wäre vielleicht noch, was man machen könnte. Ich hoffe,
dass die Kardiologen und Intensivmediziner unter ihnen jetzt nicht protestieren, aber wenn die
Patientin jetzt einen Blutdruck von 160 zu 100 hat und anhaltend diesen retro-stenalen Schmerz und
epigastischen Schmerz könnte man probatorisch ihr zum Beispiel Nitrolingual gibt, also Nitrospray
und das könnte man machen während man die Anamnese erhebt und dann kann man vielleicht nach einigen
Minuten fragen, Frau Hanke, ich habe Ihnen ja diesen Spree gegeben, haben Sie irgendetwas bemerkt, ist der
Schmerz gleichbleibend oder schlimmer geworden? Bei diesem Blutdruck kann man das sehr gut tun.
Wenn der Blutdruck jetzt sehr niedrig wäre, würde ich damit etwas zurückhaltend sein,
aber ich glaube man kann es machen, man macht da keinen Fehler mit. Aber ich denke,
wichtig ist, dass Sie bei diesen Patienten die Anamnese unterbrechen, dass aber auch den
Patienten vermitteln, also erklären, was sie machen und weshalb sie das machen. Und Sie können
natürlich dann direkt kurz, wenn Sie jetzt die Werte gesagt haben, können Sie auch ruhig sagen,
Frau Hanke, die Werte sind soweit erst mal ganz gut, der Blutdruck ist etwas erhöht, aber das andere
ist erst mal in Ordnung, aber das muss weiter kontrolliert werden, aber ich bin erst mal so weit
zufrieden. Es kann ja durchaus sein, dass das EKG noch gar nicht auffällig ist.